when mao niragongo erupted last month
veronica ran with her two children she
carried a few pots
so she could feed them but food in this
makeshift shark
is hard to come by and they have no home
to return to
lava destroyed all they had their small
tent here
barely protects them from rain and
illness
we live in misery i don't eat and i have
a stomach ache that hurts a lot
every day when i don't know what to eat
sometimes i drink water
today i didn't eat anything and there
are thousands like them
scrambling for food with no toilets or
drinking water
we see a lot of diseases linked to the
water that is not of good quality
including diuretic diseases and often a
lot of malaria too
we see many respiratory infections you
have to know
that the living conditions are a big
part of the situation
around three thousand five hundred
people lost their homes
when mount near gongo erupted last month
the government says
they must remain in shelters outside the
city of goma
while others whose homes still stand are
slowly returning
those whose houses were burned and
destroyed have to stay and wait for the
government contingency plan
because we cannot allow them to return
to their natural environment that was
burned and destroyed
by the lava and as a responsible
government we cannot ask them to rebuild
houses
but even in goma the volcanic eruption
has melted main water pipes
and damaged a major reservoir aid
agencies and the government
are working to provide emergency water
supplies
but for now life remains precarious for
the families here
as they try to survive hunger and
disease
under the shadow of one of africa's most
dangerous volcanoes
priyanka gupta al jazeera